Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to travel in time.
With the ascendancy of neural-network based
learning techniques, this previous method
enables us to take and old old black and white
movie that suffers from a lot of problems
like missing data, flickering, and more, give
it to a neural network, and have it restore
it for us.
And here, you can not only see how much better
this restored version is, but, it did take
it one step further.
It also performed colorization!
Essentially, here, we could produce 6 colorized
reference images, and the neural network uses
them as art direction and propagates all this
information to the remainder of the frames.
So this work did restoration and colorization
at the same time.
This was absolutely amazing, and now comes
something even better, today, we have a new
piece of work that performs not only restoration
and colorization, but super-resolution as
well!
What this means is that we can take an antique
photo, which suffers from a lot of issues.
Look, these old films exaggerate wrinkles
a great deal, they even even darken the lips
and do funny things with red colors.
For instance, subsurface scattering is also
missing, this is light penetrating our skin
and bouncing inside before coming out again,
and the lack of this effect is why the skin
looks a little plasticky here.
Luckily, we can simulate all these phenomena
on our computers.
I am a light transport researcher by trade,
and this is from our earlier paper with the
Activision Blizzard game development company,
this is the same phenomenon, a simulation
without subsurface scattering, and this one
is with simulating this effect.
Beautiful.
You can find a link to this paper in the video
description.
So with all these problems with the antique
photos, our question is, what did Lincoln
really look like?
Well, let’s try an earlier framework for
restoration, colorization and super resolution…and.
Well, unfortunately, most of our issues still
remain.
Lots of exaggerated wrinkles, plasticky look,
lots of detail is missing.
Can we do better?
Well, hold on to your papers, and observe
the output with the new technique.
Wow.
The restoration indeed took place properly,
brought the wrinkles down to a much more realistic
level, skin looks like skin because of subsurface
scattering, and the super resolution part
is responsible for a lot of new detail everywhere,
but especially around the lips.
Outstanding.
It truly feels like this photo has been rephotographed
with a modern camera.
And with that, please meet Time-Travel Rephotography.
And the curious thing is that all this sounds
flat out impossible.
Why is that?
Since we don’t have old and new image pairs
of Lincoln and many other historic figures,
the question naturally arises in the mind
of the curious Fellow Scholar - how do we
train a neural network to perform this?
And the answer is that we need to use their
siblings.
Now this doesn’t mean that Lincoln had a
long lost sibling that we don’t know about.
What this means is that as the input image
is fed through our neural network, we can
generate a photorealistic image of someone,
and this someone kind of resembles the target
subject, and has all the details filled in.
Then, in the next step, we can start morphing
the sibling until is starts resembling the
test subject.
With this previously existing StyleGAN2 technique,
morphing is now easy to do, but restoration
is hard, so essentially, with this, we can
skip the difficult restoration part, and just
do the easier morphing instead.
Trading a difficult problem for an easier
one.
Absolutely brilliant idea.
And if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because it
can do even more.
Age progression!
Look.
If we have only a few a few target photos
of Thomas Edison throughout his life, these
will be our yardsticks, and the algorithm
is able to generate his aging process between
these yardstick images.
And the best part is that these images have
different lighting, pose, and none of this
is an issue for the technique.
It just doesn’t care and it still works
beautifully.
Wow.
So we saw earlier that there are other methods
that attempt to do this too, at least the
colorization part.
Yes, we have colorization and other techniques
in abundance.
So how does this compare to them?
It appears to outpace all of them really convincingly.
The numbers from the user study and the algorithmically
generated scores also favor the new technique.
This is a huge leap forward.
Do you have some other applications in mind
for this new technique?
Let me know in the comments what you would
do with this or how you would like to see
it improved.
Now, of course, not even this technique is
perfect.
Blurry and noisy regions can still appear
here and there.
And note that StyleGAN2, the basis for this
algorithm came out just a little more than
a year ago.
And it is amazing that we are witnessing such
incredible progress in so little time.
My goodness.
And just imagine what the next paper down
the line will bring!
What a
time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!